johnny depp's attorney camille vasquez
has been made partner following his
legal team's victorious day in court do
you find that mr depp has proven all the
elements of defamation
answer yes
camille's new role at brown rudnick
comes days after winning the actors
defamation lawsuit against amber heard
in a press release on tuesday the law
firm says of her promotion camille's
performance during the johnny depp trial
proved to the world that she was ready
to take this next step now we are
incredibly proud of her and look forward
to what she will accomplish as our
newest partner who is the real monster
in this relationship ms heard
camille became a celebrity in her own
right amid the high profile trial where
she made waves with her
cross-examination of amber heard he
promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
you had all of the seven million dollars
for 13 months before mr depp sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities
along with sharing her excitement in the
announcement camille also takes a moment
to reflect she says i'm proud of the
uniquely talented team i've had the
privilege to lead which exemplified
teamwork and collaboration all right mr
foreperson is this the verdict of the
jury
all right is it unanimous
[Music]
that's camille and her team in a moment
of joy in court shortly after the jury
decided amber did indeed defame johnny
awarding him 15 million dollars in both
punitive and compensatory damages
hi everyone
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning
moments later camille took their
celebration outside the courthouse
that the claims against johnny depp are
defamatory and unsupported by any
evidence
we are grateful so grateful to the jury
for their careful celebration
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case
meanwhile another figure from the trial
is sharing a surprising observation when
the jury was chosen
we knew that there were going to be some
that would not see it all the way
through the court stenographer judy
bellinger says she saw jurors
periodically falling asleep during the
trial their future was dozing off were
the jurors who were dozing off were they
in the back row front row both both
both and you know they just sit there
and all of a sudden i'd see their head
drop
as she tells it one of the jurors who
was paying the most attention was an
alternate and was not involved in the
final verdict and there was
unfortunately the one alternate that was
on there she was probably the one that
listened the most i watched her facial
expression she was
very deeply into every word that was
being said and i thought she would have
made a great juror and she did not get
to see it to the end following the
verdict amber heard says she plans to
appeal the court's decision
[Music]
you